All right, now that we have created the website, we're just missing the images.
So rule of thumb, we get 25 images total for our website that has three service pages and
that does not include the header photo.
So it's 25 plus 126 and the 26 photo is the header image.
So right here where it looks blue is going to be your header photo.
There is usually the best way you can get images is just by asking the business owner
that you landed.
The reason why is because you're going to be the best pictures you can get the most
local, the most like authentic photos for this.
It's going to make the website look really local, very authentic instead of getting stock
images.
So that's what we recommend you doing.
You do need to remember two rules when you're doing that.
Number one is when you're asking the business owner for photos, make sure that they are
not being used on his own website.
A lot of the times when you're pitching and you're selling leads, what happens is the
business owner already has a social media account, a Facebook page or their own website.
So we do not, and again, we do not want to use photos that are already being used by
him or her on their website or social media because that would be copyright.
So any photos that he sends you, they need to be fresh or unused on his own platforms.
That being said, that is the first rule.
Number two, let's say he has some fresh images or he's going to take pictures for you.
And one thing that I personally do is I just say, Hey, if you don't have photos, next
time you do go on the job, just take some on your phone and usually an iPhone camera
will be pretty good.
Take them on your phone and email them to me.
And then the number two rule is make sure that the pictures that are being taken do
not have the company's logo on it.
And just be attention.
Like a lot of the time, the concrete contractors will wear a t-shirt that has their company
logo on it or they'll drive a truck that has the company logo on it.
So make sure that the pictures that you're taking from the business owner do not have
their company name on it because we are targeting this website as Queen Creek concrete.
And if in the future you ever need to switch up the business owner, you don't have to
worry about, Oh, well, it's marketing that company.
So those are the two basic rules for images.
And then one last thing, let's say you cannot get images from the business owner.
You can.
And we do use stock images.
We like to use the free trials.
So for example, just go on Google and type free stock images and we'll have a video on
how to optimize images and get, grab those images.
But right now I'm just showing you very quickly.
We use like stock Adobe, Shutterstock.
They all have free trials that you can use.
So just go ahead and take advantage of those and you're done.